Let's see a slightly more lively example.
There's a lot going on in this example, and some of it you may not have seen before.
I'm making a procedure called makegreeter that--and this is cute--
inside of it defines another procedure.
If you haven't seen this before in Python, don't worry,
but it is possible to make 1 function inside another.
Here I'm making a function called greeter
that takes a person to be talking to and prints out a particular greeting to that person.
And then this makegreeter function returns greeter this function that I just defined in here.
Wow! This is not obvious.
So down here I'm making a variable sayhello,
which is the result of making a greeter who always starts with "hello from uttar pradesh".
And then I can ask that greeter to say hello to Gracie
and also say hello to Lucknow.
So sayhello points to or references a particular version of greeter
where the greeting has been locked in to be hello from the UP.
If you haven't been there, Uttar Pradesh is a region in India.
Its capital city is Lucknow, known as The City of Nawabs.
It's known for its manufacturing and retailing
and possibly also silversmithing. Cool place. Very populous.
So here I've recopied the same code from before.
Nothing has changed except that I'm abbreviating Uttar Pradesh with u.p.
And now over here on the right I'm drawing out the chained or nested environment frames
as we're calling sayhello("gracie").
I'd like you to help me out with just the last part.
Down here in this final environment frame there's a single variable bound to a value.
I'd like you to fill in these 2 blanks so that this picture of the environment is complete.